T
THE BATTLES DOWN HERE.
BUT A LOT OF ACTIVITY HAPPENING
AROUND KYIV WHERE WE HAVE SEEN A
NUMBER OF AERIAL ATTACKS IN THE
LAST FEW DAYS.
LET'S GO TO CORRESPONDENT
ALEXANDER MARQUARDT AT THE SITE
OF THE TV TOWER HIT YESTERDAY.
>> Reporter: NOT JUST AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF ATTACKS
AROUND KYIV BUT IN KYIV AS WELL.
THIS THREE MILES FROM THE CITY
CENTER.
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH GUARDS HERE
THE YESTERDAY.
THEY SAY THIS ATTACK CAME WITH
NO WARNING.
THEY BELIEVE THERE WERE FOUR
MISSILES THAT HIT ALL ACROSS
THIS AREA, INCLUDING A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE TOWER ITSELF.
A BLACKENED AREA AROUND THE
MIDDLE OF IT, AS WELL AS WINDOWS
THAT HAVE BEEN SHATTERED.
BUT CLEARLY A NUMBER OF ROCKETS
THAT LANDED OVER HERE.
LOTS AND LOTS OF COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
WE KNOW SOME FIVE PEOPLE WERE
KILLED.
YOU CAN STILL SEE SOME OF THE
BLOOD ON THE SIDEWALK.
OF COURSE WE ARE ACROSS THE
STREET FROM THAT TOWER.
BUT JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
AT THIS BUILDING AND THE STATE
IT'S IN NOW.
IT IS COMPLETELY DESTROYED.
HERE ON THE GROUND FLOOR, THIS
IS CLEARLY A GYM.
YOU CAN SEE ALL THE GYM
EQUIPMENT, STATIONARY BIKES,
ELLIPTICAL TRAINER.
THERE IS STILL A FIRE GOING ON
THERE.
LOTS OF SMOKE COMING OUT OF THIS
BUILDING, UTTERLY DESTROYED,
JOHN.
THIS IS WHERE ONE OF THE WORST
MASSACRES OF JEWS IN WORLD WAR
II HAPPENED.
IT IS A VERY SYMBOLIC AREA.
HERE YOU HAVE AN ATTACK BY A
MAN, VLADIMIR PUTIN, WHO CLAIMS
HE IS TRYING TO DE-NAZIFY
UKRAINE ON WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY
HOLLOWED GROUPED.
THIS IS, IN THE WORDS OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TONY BLINKEN,
AN APPALLING ATTACK.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ALSO SAYING
THAT THIS IS EVIDENCE OF HISTORY
REPEATING ITSELF.
JOHN, WE HAVE HEARD TIME AND
TIME AGAIN FROM THE RUSSIANS
THAT THEY ARE THEY ARE NOT
TARGETING CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HEARD THAT CLAIM AGAIN TODAY.